hello everybody my name is Marc Lauren
welcome to battle cats I am a nerd I
mean you all knew that already but I'm a
nerd especially because I'm gonna be
playing this game with a stylus because
I like the way it feels and I feel good
when I do it so I'm gonna do that and
who are you to say I can't anyway this
is battle cats this is a mobile game
that I like very much not because the
cats in front of you are extremely
creepy and all that but that they are
but also just because it's a really
silly idea that's executed very well and
I do like that a lot
so what I'm gonna be doing here is I'm
gonna be showing you basically a kind of
broad overview of the game I played it
quite a bit already and OH
bonus item clear Empire of cats champ
two two and get the valkyrie cat okay at
this point I don't think that's a cat I
think that's a lady
I think that's a fully-formed lady I
don't think there's any cat part of her
I'm pretty sure she just has a cat on
her staff so this go you can get a cat
ticket every day yay
thank you thank you very much thank you
so much okay thank you thank you got a
free ticket this game likes to give you
a lot of free that is a hundred
percent what it is if you have you
played this game expect to just get
exploded with crap all over your screen
all the time you'll notice basic kind of
mobile games stuff but this actually has
a lot more detail to it you got your XP
in the top right you got your cat food
in the bottom right you got your store
which I'm going to avoid you got your
capsule cat you got your rare capsule
cat I'll get to those later and then you
got your missions which I got a look at
what I'm doing from one cat easy okay so
I I get some for doing the Emperor of
Darkness which is the next thing that
I'm gonna be doing I think so I
basically there's a lot of cats in this
game if you do that that's um yeah okay
just moving right on again I don't think
these I'm not sure mm-hmm
actress cat and skirt cat okay leaf cat
for nudity sake mister that's not a cat
raw Rockets Rockets bean cats - bro yeah
bean cats that's it Brock at weight
let's leave cat then
[Music]
I love this game so much art skirt cat
oh-ho-ho oh boy like her cat oh you
gauger with biker cat actress cat go
back to uh actors kept their thirds
going no I'm going back to mother cat
because I just want to see how that
looks in the people if you didn't get
the idea that there's a lot of cats in
this game there's a lot of cats I can
switch out what cats I want in what
slots and I have a bunch of different
slots that I have here so these are all
different like formations yeah I'm just
gonna buy more slots ok so these are my
pre-made ones and I'm gonna keep those
and I'm not gonna change those but I'm
gonna make the ones that I want so let's
get off a basic macho cat all right
let's go gross cat cuz I love me some
gross cat okay okay yep please okay
mythical Titan cat I like that devil cat
this goes all right now devil cat no
let's go zombie yeah devil sumo cat mmm
Adam sumo cat all right we're gonna go
hang on so now that's a good that's a
good distribution of like costs because
costs are a big thing in this game like
it's a monetary thing for the battles
you'll see the battles soon just give me
you give me a second oh oh that's
different okay um all right well alright
there's mother cat I gotta get mother
cat in there that's an absolute must
tights cat oh yes please panties cat all
right I got I got tights cat I just I
only have one room for one more and has
probably got to be bra cats I think
anyway okay let's just do actually let's
say it like this I'm gonna use one super
high expensive one because that seems
important that I should do I do I'm
gonna do the peach angels no
Dragonslayer no heartful nurse no no
let's go heartful nurse all right that's
good enough
oh dammit thought though no arias been
discovered
Wow facility 999 a well I can't go there
just yet just go out to the Mellow
fields real quick go go for that see you
later
the search begins and then I'll never
see you again so see ya okay so we're
gonna start off by going to a moan and
yeah I'll show you how to battle go it
goes a little like this you see that
going up like that okay that's good go
this squirrel come get the muscles you
think you can beat the muscles the
answer is probably no the answers a
whole lot of maybe nope but I'm gonna
get you here and watch out for momma hey
momma hey momma how you doing how you
doing mom here comes another momma would
bang oh my god Oh
almost as much as I love it okay there's
bondage can I go get the mistress back
there we go okay there they're a pair I
can't I can't keep them away from each
other
no matter what I do no matter how hard I
try literally I can't keep them away
from each other okay so this is where is
where things get a little dicey so you
gotta yo hey devil are you doing you got
to eat your economy up so that you can
make more units whenever you need them
and then if they get too close
Luther I don't owe you I don't like the
way you're wiggling like that I don't
think the wiggle is a good strategy to
beat them but I want more leg ease oh
yeah there we go
I looked at these ladies somehow that's
worse somehow that's just a lot worse I
don't know why it's worse but somehow it
just is
gonna let them get nice and close and
I'm gonna okay that's whatever so now
this Lady Jaye super tough probably uh
it's cool anyway so yeah it's just a lot
of this it's a lot of strategy once your
max level in the economy it's just
all-out war so you just got to get your
units out as fast as you can and the
right strategical order and whatever
looks most horrible in front of you
that's usually what I go for I mean at
the end of the day it's really like no
super right way to go about this so long
as you're just weighing doodling them as
hard as you can embrace the wilderness I
don't think so I don't think so
ain't gonna embrace nothing especially
now what's on this failed and whatnot
that's too many hearts oh good it's from
the lady and not from the dominatrix
lady over there alright let's see if I
can reach him
okay I can read to the whole field good
I can't believe I'm whaling on the oh my
god it looks like she has legs yes so if
if weird is up your alley this game is
right up your alley like 100% this game
is completely for you not bad in any way
shape or form and I don't know this is
kind of the perfect time mister the
combo oh that's got to be bad for your
spine lady huh
bad for my eyes boom bah bah bah okay
this one's pretty much in the bag now
see the moon ain't so bad once you get
everything absolutely also this dude so
this is a cat god you call me I'm God
the first advent the cat God appears
normally you need cat food to get help
at this time it's free at the icon I'm
gonna request it alright thank you God
thank you very much god oh boy
there we go see this is a complete waste
cuz I didn't need this why you know I
just oh oh why is oh yeah oh and there's
no cooldown on oh that's so nice yes so
nice get the macho cats out there
I mean I'm gonna win no matter what good
stop always good the ball is bouncing
get that but there's Bob always market
those Bobby's bouncing I can't deploy
anymore what are you out of your gourd
get those Bob is going oh come on now
okay well the boobies are bouncing over
oh they can't keep up oh they just can't
keep up so yeah I win I guess yeah there
you go
and there she blows I won I won I won
it's mine the money the money's mine
there you have it conquered the world
with cats with a horrible horrible
monstrous cats after all the battles the
world was overrun by the battle cats a
government of cats by the cats for the
cats is the new world
well that's what I thought in the end
nothing really mad nothing really
changed anyways congratulations to the
battle cats thank you battle cats battle
cats forever yes so if this sense of
humor is right I mean if this totally
gripping narrative is right up your
alley
this games for you and ah thanks for
playing oh you're welcome
well that's it then all's well that ends
oh a new chapter for Empire of cats
is available well see remember what I
said buy this game gives you a whole
bunch of stuff global cap has been
increased you guys couldn't become even
more powerful all clear bonus yeah so
yeah that wasn't anywhere near the end
of the game so I yep there it is revival
of Bahamut cat so yeah I can upgrade my
cats now so that's pretty cool I got to
remember which ones I want to upgrade
and which ones I definitely don't want
to upgrade okay I'm gonna have a lot of
these a lot of these cheaper ones and
then I'm gonna make some big honking
bongos we're gonna make the badass crew
and then the cheapo crew no offense
cheapo crew you're just not very badass
upgrade upgrade upgrade upgrade upgrade
I get my economy back up yeah there we
go
yeah you workers you're gonna work so
good yeah that's important I gotta be
careful I'm gonna waste all my XP or am
i oh god I just wasted all my XP I said
I wasn't gonna do it and then I did
exactly that
well no I don't want to buy it
whatever screw you Oh face face cat um
yeah I'm gonna change out one of them
for face cat instead of a son who needs
a son
okay so there's um if you thought that
was the only thing in the game there's
there's a lot of other things of the
game there's zombie outbreaks which I'll
get to later there's into the future
which is pretty cool event stage I've
never done that
catclaw dojo let's go into the future
I'm enough for cats oh boy so I think I
did I quit the right one did I quit well
we're gonna find out yeah it's the right
one it's the right one oh yes sir it's
the right one all right oh yeah give me
that stuff I always like to do a economy
first I'm really into economy economic
no Merkel's pirate I love them I bet all
hate face I hate that mmm hate that
greatly hate that very big leaf Oh Chomp
Chomp er here comes face man yeah that's
yeah that's the worst thing I've ever
seen yeah that's that's just awful yeah
that's that's awful yeah so yeah that's
that's horrible all right anyway glad my
eyes have now captured that forever oh
it's even worse the way the tax oh oh oh
that's oh I wish I could scrub that from
my brain oh my god we released a big boy
well I got a release a big boy of my own
you think you're the only one with big
boys oh just you wait big boy I've got a
big boy coming yeah we're cops don't big
boy what do you think you can get rid of
my virus oh that's big that is in fact a
big boy here comes face whatever it's
vastly more important to get the upgrade
as soon as possible yeah oh I hate face
if I stop him uh-huh hate that okay
there are coming okay I'm just gonna
start pumping man my yard buh buh buh
buh okay so it looks like my big guy
didn't actually kill that big guy which
is not really according to Stan hey God
hey can you uh can you help me out here
I would like what is this healing Oasis
no baby boom I do like that I'll be like
that god bless you I didn't sneeze all
enemies will be blown to the enemy's
castle lightning strikes I'll just do
the enemy blowing can you just be to
blow those enemies down away just
okay thanks man thank you
thank you thank you just gave me some
breathing room that's all I really
needed thank you thank you buddy
love you all right so this is gonna you
well that's a giraffe that's the worst
thing all right so that's gonna give me
enough time to get some more money what
oh you're licking him uh okay well I
thought it was gonna give me enough rum
apparently did not okay just need to get
you out of the way I just need to get
you guys out of the way we need to get
you guys out of the way um um um um um
boy oh boy oh boy oh oh I'm taking some
tablets hang on God hey God oh listen uh
can you you just blow them again I just
just just a second just big old fart II
foo all the way over to the back there
that'd be great if you could do that
thank you
why are they so strong hey come on a way
come on guys okay God listen God I
listen I'm gonna need you to do some a
little bit better here cuz this is just
really sucking the backed it so if you
could just like whoosh um right out of
the air just zip zap Zoop be - boo BAM
zippy zap Zoop Zippo zip zap Zoop
and they're not even close to dead but I
got some money out of it so that's what
I really need
thank you okay and let's flood the
battlefield I've got my big bonking I'm
dead guys listen it's fine watch this do
you think you think I'm not watching
this live macho cats here you think I'm
not watching yeah I am watching I'm
watching all right oh not again
this is tough oh man I only got the boss
down to 98 yeah I think it's just cuz
like those characters are not upgraded
so what I got to do what I gotta do I'm
just gonna go ahead and get more XP with
my cat food cuz I got a lot of that so I
might as well just buy more XP there's
two Millie there's two Millie
okay see I've already got panty legs so
I really need to sex it up a little bit
with something else you know what I'm
saying
yeah you probably you you Larry knows
what I'm talking about
yeah Larry knows yeah all right got a
gold macho what's the same price yeah
whatever I had more bonus levels on the
other one I like pole vaulting that's
pretty cool and fits right in the bill
there Jesse bathtub there we go that's
the more like it
that's more like you dancing more like
it oh yeah your thumbs up oh you're
gonna get vaulted watch oh it doesn't
seem like the most effective tactic but
the body slam I do like it we're about
ready to get the sexy Cree okay there's
the boss there's the boss but the boss
not gonna do nothing the boss ain't
gonna do nothing you know what's that
boss gonna do nothing a whole lot of
nothing you know you want to know why
I've got everything I need right here
here comes a big sexy combo well boom
the legs are a little farther behind
than I thought they'd be sorry about
that I'm gonna save up for this last
upgrade cuz I need that money I gotta
get that money oh I gotta get that money
you know I'm gonna get that money what
am I gonna get that money you know about
me I'll get that money cuz you know how
it is I get the money and the money is
mine okay the money is mine now this
flight is gonna turn around
from here to Tuesday good legs first oh
no no way no body body's worried my legs
get zapped oh yeah here comes here comes
the pain train destination your face no
boy the pain train is coming a little
too close to a marklar station if you
could just take the pain train just kind
of like change tracks on pain train
there like I said the pain trains just a
little too close to marklar station good
crash in a market blow Central and I
don't like that a lot of blood flow all
the hippos dead oh the hippo died
oh hell yeah oh yeah yeah you think you
think you think you think you don't
think now you can't think how can you
think when you got this many enemies
staring you down yeah you can't think oh
here comes a combo hang on hang on hang
on oh god please listen listen
I got something in my eye God can you
blow it out thank you thank you for that
also I see the Souls going up to
heaven up there hope you see him soon
okay now that I got the breathing room I
just lost all the breathing room because
those guys are fast I'm sure that
bathtub cat just pulled out a gun
alright I probably could have been fine
if I didn't use the wind blast because
didn't give me that much breathing room
but you know I just wanted to be safe
rather than sorry
there we go Oh get whomp Oh sucks for
you oh no boss coming down your way to
save you oh yeah that feels good oh that
first there you go and your dunzo your
duns oh yeah dunzo boom baby boom baby
boom baby boom baby I did it oh hell
yeah
alright I also want to show you
something else like I said there was
zombies right and I told you that I was
gonna get those zombies so we're gonna
go find those zombies cuz they randomly
spawned somewhere there it is Norway
poor Norway okay so zombies a little
different zombie snake
oh they buried so the reason the costs
are different is because I'm back in the
old chapter so yeah though the level
caps are smaller those zombie gorillas
sonmi yeah so things aren't gonna be as
difficult back here spot even so yeah
it's pretty cool oh no they fighting
back hang on a second hang on a second
oh we got purple the zombies I guess
they just bury themselves and they move
beyond you know that's okay there you go
yeah get out of here yeah Eddie and easy
peasy lemon squeezy receive ten cat food
that's why you do the zombies one
because you can get captured and you
need cat food so that is most of the
game but also you can get cat capsules
Oh horrible I got charged yay so that's
this game there's a lot to do a lot to
do it's a lot of fun I like it a lot is
a great time-waster it's super weird and
I mean sometimes weird is exactly what
you need out of game if you like cats
and you like bizarre cats and you like
being scared by cats and you like a
really dry Japanese sense of humor then
this game is for you also the developers
of the game are running a contest of
some sort there's a giveaway component
to it if you make fan art of this game
and I'm sure that's not too hard but
also could be very scary so if you make
fan art of this game you can submit it
for a contest for a chance to win some
prizes the hashtag that they want you to
submit it under is hashtag your battle
cat and if you want to play this game
for yourself which I highly recommend
you can click the links in the
description below there right below this
video right in the top line you don't
even need to click there in the top line
in the description you don't even need
to click read more to see more about
them you can just click on them and
it'll take you to the download page
where you can get the game for free so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye